what do writers get wrong about writing
supporting characters oh well I don't
know that they necessarily get it wrong
but I think one thing that could make
some supporting characters stronger and
screenplays in general stronger is
connecting the supporting characters to
the theme a little bit more I think
sometimes writers throw in you know the
wacky sidekick or you know a supporting
character who's just really colorful and
therefore comedic effect or you know a
sort of a distraction from the a story
but really you want your screenplay to
be a collection of things that are all
having the same conversation right so
you want your screenplay to be having
one conversation all the way through and
all of those pieces should connect to
that conversation they should all fall
under that umbrella we're just gonna mix
mixed metaphors so but yeah so when
you're when you're inventing your
supporting characters if you can think
about their relationship with the theme
that's a useful a useful way to invent a
supporting character that feels
integrated into the fabric of the story
and has a function in your story as well
because your supporting characters
should be pushing your character either
toward or away from the lesson that
they're trying to learn from this series
of events right that is the lesson of
the theme and so if you're supporting
character has a function that relates to
that theme so either they set a good
example that leads your character toward
this you know revelation that they're
gonna have eventually or if they are a
cautionary tale if you don't learn the
lesson of the theme this is what you'll
turn into those are just two examples
but you can connect your supporting
characters to the theme in ways like
that and then that will both make them
feel integrated into the that one
conversation that your story is having
and then also contribute to the growth
of your character either by pushing them
toward the lesson that they need or
providing more conflict and causing them
to struggle toward that lesson as well
well maybe we can move on to another
film and not my idea which it may be
bridesmaids okay so if we look at the
supporting characters and that yeah how
did that
move the main character more toward her
goal well so interestingly those Brides
the collection of bridesmaids in
bridesmaids has sort of like two aspects
to them that I think is really
interesting on the one hand they each
provide a different outlook on marriage
or a different sort of like phase of
marriage relationships right so you have
kind of the the newly married doe-eyed
you know idealist you have the the like
resolutely single playing the field
Melissa McCarthy right you have the
woman who's been married so long she has
like three sons and she she is tired of
her husband right
you have Helen who's kind of the board
trophy wife and I think that's it right
that's those four and then Kristen Wigg
and so they each represent kind of a
different version of marriage and you
know the whole where we're setting this
story in the world of weddings and
marriage and getting married and all
that stuff so that's very fitting but if
you look at it as well they each provide
a different sort of attitude about
growth and change right so and that's
really the journey that Kristen Wigg is
on in this in this movie she's trying to
get unstuck from her life
each of those characters have if you
could look at it that they each have
sort of a different perspective or
relationship to just being stuck or
being happy you know making progress in
your life so the newly married one she's
excited for everything that's to come
like all she has is sort of like
rainbows and roses in her future and she
can't wait to be married forever I think
she says that at one point in the in the
movie the the woman who's been married
too long she had she feels stuck and in
a rut in her in her marriage like this
is how things are this is how they will
always be it's awful she needs to escape
to Vegas right the the woman Helen who
is kind of the trophy wife and the big
antagonist she she is not happy with the
way things are in her life but she is
going about changing them in you know in
maybe an unhealthy way
could look at it right so she and
Kristen Wigg are sort of both equally as
stuck in their lives but they're stuck
in very different lives and Who am I
missing Oh Melissa McCarthy she is she
welcomes all change she says yes to
everything you know so they all have a
relationship to sort of change and being
stuck we're making progress or you know
that that kind of like realm which is
really what the thematic stuff of that
movie is excellent I love it I want to
watch it okay
you